Henry Blodgett silicon alley media well
I have been blogging myself for a couple
of years I've been a journalist for
about five years and actually had done
it a long time ago before I was on Wall
Street but I was friend of mine in New
York Kevin Ryan who was the CEO of
double click in the old days basically
had an idea to do a site focused on New
York and it seemed like a great
opportunity to start a company and
relatively shortly thereafter we
realized it was going to be much broader
than that and we started to focus on the
whole industry five to ten years it's
incredible I go back so we'll go back
ten years or a little more than ten
years when I first started working on
Wall Street companies published their
financial information what we have to do
well we go to the library and we might
get microfilm or we might get a cd-rom
and we print out a stack like this for
every financial filing and go back to
the cube and so forth and companies
would have conference calls where they
might publish a press release and if
they did they would fax it to the
analyst or they might just call a couple
of analysts and say here's what the
results are and publish those in your
models no information available to
investors and and and so forth and so
you fast forward to today we're an
incredible amount of information is
available at every investors fingertips
and you have companies doing their calls
sometimes in video sometimes online you
have all financial information available
instantly online you have fully featured
spreadsheets the investment world has
changed so much and then obviously
looking at the way professionals work
within that where you now have fully
featured mobile devices that are
basically convenient mini computers that
you can work on and phone on an email on
and so forth
I do what I do often on a couch at home
with my computer open and my computer
pretty much is my office and when I go
to the office I'm thankful to say that
my office is finally almost a paperless
office there's been this myth of the
paperless office forever and every year
just more and more trees get killed and
more and more favor is created in my
office fortunately now that I haven't
aggressively given out a physical mail
address I'm now finally not getting much
physical mail anymore so there's not a
lot of paper around and it's very clean
but my office really is my computer
that's it it goes everywhere and it's
supplemented by a smaller mobile device
but with that and a connection to the
internet wireless connection that's all
I need anywhere and hopefully that will
only get more ubiquitous as we go
forward I think the office ultimately is
going to come down your laptop and your
your mobile device and for a lot of
people really is the mobile device if
you're not producing whether I'm in the
writing business and so I have to be
around cameras and around a
fully-fledged keyboard and so forth lots
of people don't and for them it really
is a single handheld unit it's pretty
much all you need especially if your job
is to make decisions and to talk to
people and communicate rather than
producing a product I think so I think
the people are now learning is certainly
a couple of years ago or going back ten
years ago facetime was incredibly
important and that camaraderie and
leading the troops while you're there is
very important and and it's still
important to some extent you have to
find some way to capture that but I
think people have gotten a lot more used
to the idea of telecommuting and people
around the world and as long as you have
a presence instant messaging for example
is very profound you have the presence
of feeling as though you're in the
presence of somebody even when you're
4,000 miles apart and that's starting to
change things the other thing that's
starting to change things is the gas
crisis where you actually have companies
saying yeah we would prefer to have
employees here in the office but not if
it's going to cost them a hundred
dollars of gas
here and back and all that time we'll
buy them an internet connection as a
result we in our company we definitely
have a fully virtual communication
system where it's a ton of email
obviously a ton of the instant messaging
we use skype sometimes we and we're all
connected the internet we're all on the
sites that we produce constantly so
sometimes it's in comments there we
haven't quite gotten to the Twitter
level to communicate with each other yet
but probably not far away and and again
there's this sense that even if you're
not actually sitting next to somebody
because of the presence in instant
messaging and some of the other services
you feel as though you are you are in a
space and it sounds corny people have
been talking about that forever but you
really are in the same space the same
workspace even though you're not in the
same physical proximity and that again
once the team gets used to that sure
once in a while you want to be in front
of people you want to shake hands and
it's you get a totally different thing
out of that but once people get used to
it it's amazing how consistently you can
run with everybody distributed well I
think it's great for four tons of
reasons and the one is the obviously the
ability to spend more time with my
family and and so forth just in
commuting time it's easier to commute
when it's not the crowd and and so forth
I mean obviously that raises its own
issues and I'm sure marriages have been
broken up and things like that with the
crackberry and people online all the
time and so forth but I at least for me
my work is what is incredibly
interesting to me it's what i want to do
most of the time and so to be able to do
that anywhere and to sneak in a few
minutes here and there with hopefully
without just disrupting the home life or
what-have-you is great the ability to
again go to if there's some trip you
have to take to be able to work
relatively effortlessly on the way and
when you're there suddenly that time is
productive I just think it's freeing and
it certainly freeze the company to say
to people who aren't based in New York
or aren't in a particular location we'd
be glad to have you work with us and as
long as we can figure out a way to make
it work and we
feel like we're on the same team and so
her you pretty much can be anywhere and
and again for me that's a joy
you